there's so much romance in EXO Kitty
your character gets to spark a little
electricity with I believe three
different characters was there one
relationship that you thought that makes
the most sense for our girl kitty I'm a
big fan of the enemies to lovers tro can
you please get out of my life I don't
want to be next to you either so I would
have to say Amino I would love to see
them attempt at least
you know navigate those feelings a
little bit I think that would be a
really interesting Dynamic to play on I
think either Kitty and Minho or Kitty
and Yuri okay
[Applause]
yes because you know it's just a classic
romance uh like formula of like oh they
hate each other we want them to love
each other you know because we all want
the unity at the end of it so whatever
like there's not Nemesis we're like oh
we want them to be friends yes why do
you think Yuri made a good match
I think it's also just because it's also
so unexpected too it's like okay
boyfriend
potential and then there's like whoa
okay kitties find out something new
about herself and it's just it just adds
another layer to it dear Lara Gina Marco
operation kiss is actually happening
this is not all about a boy this is for
me EXO Kitty something that I love about
her is that she does everything with her
full heart and she does what feels right
for her not because someone else is
pushing her into it or because she
thinks it's expected or she should so I
think whoever Kitty feels right is is
the ship that I support I want her to do
what she wants to do and I also think
she doesn't need a person I love how at
the end of the season she is on her own
and she's treating herself and so many
doors have just been opened and like
crashed down in front of her that the
world is kind of constantly turning like
the ups and downs don't stop once they
start and she's kind of alone at the end
but she feels very proud of herself and
I'm very proud of her that she's giving
herself the space to figure that out and
to not force anything or rush anything
and be honest with what she wants I have
to say the last scene the Mino scene
with this airplane that one did get to
me this is adorable I did love it but I
mean what a gesture I think day and
kitty they their timeline was exactly
right for them but I am really happy
with their relationship and I'm really
glad that kitty got that experience and
and like she says you're the perfect
first boyfriend I think that's totally
true so I I love the relationship but I
agree that it's like it had its time I
would say I was like open to whatever
kid he wants what I really liked about
the romance with Yuri not because that
Yuri fits well to Kitty it was because
that kitty's discovering a whole
different role for her and she's she was
she was not afraid of it well she was
but like she admits it and then like
faces it and I really like cheered for
her when Kitty was what day I really
liked the innocent love that's what made
it so special and made it so
heartwarming and everything but at the
same time I also can't blame minho's
feelings towards Kitty at the same time
I can't blame him well yeah no because
like it's your best friend oh that's the
thing see I can say something about this
you wouldn't be mad with yourself
it's a good question so all let's say so
the reason why I always say this is
because when minnow was all about being
loyal to his friends q and day he was
there all the way and but then there
were so many parts during during the
whole episode throughout the season
where he got rejected by his friends and
there's girls or whatever right so he
just started thinking like okay you know
what it's fine it's fine everything's
fine but then later on there was this
huge push when they decided to blame
Minho like well it was a whole
misunderstanding where he pushed me
against the wall and everything like and
I was like wait hold up I'm your
freaking best friend here you should be
careful and what's going on here so like
I think I think once um everything was a
bit more subtle down everything he knows
everyone's relationship he's like okay
you know what I'm gonna shoot my shot
now forget my friends because they
didn't really care about me so let's go
for it so I think that's why I kind of
support me now as well I think I fell in
love with you
a little bit
or
a lot what was your reaction to that
epic Cliffhanger at the end of season
one yeah you're like holding on for dear
life first reaction like there must be a
season two there must be sorry about
this like it can't end it like this yeah
we were watching that ending scene
yesterday with all together for the
first time and we're like whoa like in
five minutes ten different things
happened for Kitty and like all three
different Kitty was like
whoa
okay so that leaves so much juicy stuff
for a season two what is the storyline
that you are most excited to tackle in a
fingers crossed season two I want to see
her continue to follow her heart and do
what feels right and push herself I
think Kitty pushes a lot of other people
in her life and that's in a loving way
always but she definitely is open for
lots of other characters if she wants
people to you know go to their comfort
zone and do their best but I think
sometimes she puts it on other people
more than she puts it on herself and for
her to really do what scares her I think
is really fun to see which we we do see
in this season as well well actually
what I was like really I was like
expecting was we had things about us a
lot but there could be more things
without those parents and like new
stories and like not only between like
characters and kitty like there could be
like things with Nino and me like
there's a lot of things
yeah everyone's family I would love to
see more of Q's background his family
life and stuff like he was one of the
only characters we didn't see season one
of his personal life a little bit so I
would love to explore that especially
him being a queer character and how he
was brought up necessarily and how he's
coming to terms with all of that kind of
stuff I would love to like take a peek
into his past a little bit there's so
many possibilities and there's so many
ways that it could go that I I'm dying
to see what that Vision could look like
or what the future could look like but I
think no matter what if she stays true
to herself it'll be good
[Music]